hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
today's video is sponsored by cheerios
and i'm gonna be taking you
into my kitchen for a full week of my
breakfast
hope you brought your appetite so first
let's talk about my sponsor cheerios
february is national heart health month
and i think this is a really important
cause to bring some awareness to
since 2.4 million canadians are
diagnosed with some form of heart
disease
this cause is actually very near and
dear to my heart
because a number of my family members
have some form of heart disease
so to help bring the heart health
conversation to the forefront
cheerios has added happy heart shapes to
limited edition boxes of cheerios
i mean look how cute these are so
sweet cheerios has always been a go-to
cereal in my house both my son and i
love it
not only is it super tasty but one cup
of cheerios made with oats contains
35 of the fibers that have been shown to
help lower cholesterol
so it can help support a heart-healthy
diet and to help increase your physical
activity
cheerios is giving away a bunch of
fitness inspired prizes so definitely
check out
their limited edition boxes to enter
also check out my disclaimer
on the screen and in the description
below including a reminder that
these are not suggestions of what you
should be eating or how much you should
be eating every day um this is just what
i'm eating and of course it varies every
single day so always
just listen to your body and you do you
and also fyi
i usually have like two breakfasts plus
a snack before noon
because my morning starts hella early so
yeah you adjust these recipes
asling take it away bigger portion
smaller portion whatever you need to do
especially if your morning routine isn't
as crazy as mine
okay folks well without a do let's dive
in
so mondays have to be super simple and
easy and fast
so i'm gonna be making my yogurt cereal
bowl i top some
good quality full fat yogurt with a
handful of 100
whole grain cheerios then i add some
sliced banana
and a hearty dollop of natural peanut
butter the crunchy one
for good texture
[Music]
how good is this look i am super excited
so good we've got that creaminess of
that yogurt the crunch of the 100 whole
grain cheerios
sweetness of those bananas and you got
to get that peanut butter in there
this is when i use a favorite breakfast
as well
and he's been eating cheerios since he
was like a little baby because they've
got like
a gram of sugar per serving and they're
really great for
developing that pincer grass but mama's
gonna eat this all on her own
before he wakes up
now tuesday is freezing out so i'm
feeling like some
warm cozy oats so we're going to do a
abby's kitchen
recipe staple a classic over here
my pros aka protein oats so to a sauce
pot
i add my water and my oats and i let
that come to a boil with a pinch of salt
and cinnamon
then i take some egg whites and i whisk
them up until they're super frothy and
light
once the oats have absorbed most of the
liquid i add the eggs in
over low heat and i beat them into the
mixture to prevent them from scrambling
then i add some mashed
ripe banana and vanilla extract and i
pop the lid on to let it sit
and poof up you can top it however you
like but today i was feeling like some
apples
raisins and these awesome local spiced
pecans
[Music]
all right so this is probably one of my
all-time favorite breakfast
and i just like switch up the toppings
depending on what i have on hand or
what's in season what's in the fridge or
whatever
and this is actually from the mindful
glow cookbook which side note folks if
you don't already have it
check out the link below the mindful
clip cookbook radiant recipes for being
the healthiest happiest you
so yeah i'll leave that amazon link
below
[Music]
light as air and no it does not taste
like eggs it tastes like a cloud
if a cloud had flavor and i knew what a
cloud tasted like
i'm quite confident that this would be
it i'm going in
also you guys all told me to get the
ember mug
and let me tell you this is
life-changing finally
i have never experienced hot coffee
like this before if you are a busy
person and you never get to have
hot coffee get yourself one of these
mugs i promise you
thank you internet for showing me the
light
okay wednesday pretty busy day so i'm
feeling like something portable
and on the go would be a good idea so
we're gonna be doing my egg and black
bean breakfast wraps so i crack a few
eggs into a bowl
and i beat them with a splash of milk
with some salt and pepper
then i heat a pan with some olive oil
add in some diced bell peppers and then
i add my eggs and i just lightly
scrambled them over low
heat i top it off with some shredded
cheddar some canned black beans
and some baby spinach and i fold
everything together
then i smash a little avocado into a
whole grain tortilla
top it off with my egg mixture add a
little salsa and then i attempt to wrap
it up and yep
it is a struggle wrapping is always a
struggle
i overshot it i always overshoot
the wrap size i should have double
wrapped it
anyway when or if i do manage to get it
to all stay together
i definitely try to eat it as fast as
possible before the contents just end up
everywhere i'm serious about this stuff
[Music]
that is good and you can actually make
the filling and then just kind of
put in the fridge and then wrap them up
in the morning if you want to kind of
batch prep these but i do
suggest again because it's a mess
situation wait to wrap them until you're
ready to eat them
all right back to it folks i'm not going
to make you watch me eat a whole burrito
might be a little suggestive
right friends it's thursday and i'm
feeling like something sweet
so this fully loaded breakfast sweet
potato definitely does the trick
i give my sweet potato a little poke and
then i can either roast it or
nuke it in the microwave until it's
super soft then i slice it down the
middle
and i fluff up the innards and then we
add some fun toppings folks
so you can do yours however you want but
i loaded mine up with some nut butter
some greek yogurt lots of fresh berries
a little cinnamon hemp hearts and a
little bit of granola
oh my gosh yes
so good i even like the sweet potato
skin am i weird
tell me if i'm weird i like that it's
friday folks
we made it
fridays typically i go to the studio to
shoot so it's
really crazy chaotic here in the morning
and that is where
overnight oats come into play and
tiramisu
overnight oats is so good
so the night before i mixed together
some rolled oats
almond milk mascarpone cheese yes
so good plus some full fat greek yogurt
or
pureed cottage cheese and i add just a
hint of maple syrup to taste
and then i let that sit in the fridge
overnight then
the next morning i dip some ladyfingers
into some brewed espresso oh my gosh so
good
layer those into a container with the
prepared oats and finish with like a
fancy pants dusting of cocoa powder
i mean you can do however many layers
you want however many cookies you want
to eat for breakfast
um but i usually do like two layers tell
me
of a more efficient and delicious way
to get your caffeine fix in the morning
come on it's good you gotta get a cookie
in there also i'm not gonna let
the extra espresso go to waste here
bottoms up
and it's the weekend so this is
typically when i get my fresh sourdough
delivered
and that my friends means avocado toast
everything
bagel avocado toast and yes i know i say
bagel weird don't judge me uh they're
called bagels
anyways i add a little bit of oil to a
nonstick skillet over medium-low heat
and i crack a couple eggs down there i
add a little bit of salt and pepper and
i cook them until the whites are opaque
but the yolks are still good and runny
next i toast a little sourdough
smear it with some cream cheese and i
smash a ripe avocado right on top
why cream cheese and avocado i don't
know folks this is my breakfast
and this is how i like it because i like
the the tang
of the cream cheese with the creamy
lusciousness
of the avocado but of course if you
don't like cream cheese or you're dairy
free
you can leave that out i then throw on
some roasted red peppers that i had meal
prepped for a little bit of extra veg on
there
top it off with my fried eggs sprinkle
with some feta cheese
and then douse it with everything but
the bagel seasoning
yes friends
this is good
normally i am so not a fork and knife
breakfast gal
but i feel like that's that's the only
way this is going down
without a fight even cold egg
is good when there's avocado and
everything bagel
seasoning thrown in the mix
and finally it is sunday and that means
it's time for a little bit of meal prep
and my sheet pan protein pancakes is a
huge
family hit so into a food processor i
add some cottage cheese
oat flour ground flax eggs
ripe banana vanilla extract lots of
cinnamon
salt and baking powder and i puree it
until it's super smooth
then i pour it into a greased sheet pan
spread it out into a nice thin layer
and top it off with some sliced berries
or fruit i also add a sprinkle of hemp
hearts because
you guys know i put that on everything
bake it off at 425 degrees fahrenheit
for about 12 minutes and i slice it into
squares or strips
and drown that goodness in some sunday
morning maple syrup
you can keep these in the fridge or you
can freeze them for the week or months
ahead
by putting them between sheets of wax or
parchment paper so they don't all
clump together
i am so ready to dig in gotta get that
maple syrup
i know that he loves this too so he's
gonna be quite excited that we have a
whole sheet pan
of pancakes to work through this week
so folks i hope that gave you a little
bit of breakfast inspiration to help
pull you out of the breakfast rut um
again a big thank you to cheerios for
sponsoring this video
if you liked it definitely give it the
thumbs up leave me a comment below with
any other fun
vlog ideas that you want to see me do
subscribe to the channel
and i'll see you next time on abby's
kitchen bye
you